hey I'm Peter Rubin & I'm Kelly Rubin
this is Crosby and this is split screen
because we know there's always two sides
to every story in every movie every game
every TV show TV shows like Silicon
Valley which came back for season two on
Sunday it fits and I still can't believe
that I actually watched this show hmm
because it is just not my demographic
like if you drew a Venn diagram there's
them and there's me and there's very
little overlap going on there which is a
you know that's a criticism that's often
leveled at the real Silicon Valley and
and I think mike judge heard some of
some of those criticisms about seasons
because when we come back we have the
game from Pied Piper kind of on the cusp
of getting funded right but also there
they're all of a sudden they're women
everywhere I got in the first 10 minutes
there are more women than in the entire
first season in the first two minutes it
even before the credits crazy night by
the end they're gone in this back to
Silicon Valley as usual well I think
that's part of a kind of what might
judge did he had this kind of did two
different strategies on one hand he was
like here's some women for sure I heard
that criticism and I'll and I'll cast
the role that was you know vacated by
the actor Peter Gregory who died every
offseason I felt like this new woman
yeah Susan Cryer from from two guys and
a girl i think is the last place we saw
her but she's kind of perfect she has
that kind of Kwazii asperger e vc yeah
she doesn't make eye contact is very
weird for stilted and strange yeah but
on the other hand he doubled down on the
bro stuff Erlich the kind of head of
their house put his little balls on a VC
conference table like a literal double
nail a literal do it's like a quadruple
double dump me there's a lot going on
but like he was like I'll give you this
and I'll also give you that I refuse to
not be Mike Judge yes right yes and I
really like that cuz it I think that's
most of the reason that i watch I'm like
oh mike judge he knows that's higher
but at the same time I still can't tell
what part satire and what parts real
because it feels very real to me because
I see this world from the outside it's
kind of like this anthropological study
of oh this is what these guys do behind
closed doors this is how all this money
is made this is what goes on and I do
think that one of the things that makes
it that's nice about it is it kind of
translate to those weird things that are
inside the tech bubble like these
astronomical valuations that have little
to do with with a company's kind of
utility in the real world or compression
algorithms I'm saying like hell useful
does this compression algorithm I don't
know but yep I'm they're like yay but
you know what to equate it to
metaphorically yes I do thanks for that
dick joke from Buster there's a series
of tubes yeah just like the internet
yeah funny more on the internet which
we'll be talking about in coming weeks I
guess how's that for a segue we'll see
you again gonna be people out on segways
and razor e200 if a real cig way there
will be segways outside local buses and
Google and guys on zynga sweatshirts and
we'll see them now but we'll see all of
you next week on The Next Food screen oh
yes